bonjour bienvenue dans ma discothèque le
milton à baudre juste à côté de saint lô
ville de préfecture et normalement
hilton ça ressemble à ça
[Musique]
vivement j'ai tellement envie de revoir
sa copie pensa le jour je le sais j'y
pense déjà je sais qu'à 2h30 jeu verra
peut-être à un moment un coup dur à la
soirée je compte en est pas content même
temps que je préfère partager
voilà de cette année enfin cette année
peut-être un an et demi voire peut-être
je sais pas mais quand on a été hyper
longue comme à face et la folie pendant
ce temps là
[Musique]
à saint lô privé de son travail et de
revenus depuis plus de 10 mois à cause
de la crise sanitaire
voilà comment ce patron de boîte de nuit
et père de famille fait face aux
difficultés tant financière que
psychologique
je dors très mal je suis je suis hyper
sensible au bruit
d'habitude je vous l'avais la fatigue du
week-end ce qu'on a on est quand même un
peu décalé un an de venir entre le
week-end et la semaine
je dormais très très bien et puis bon
les affaires allaient bien donc pas trop
inquiet quoi même si on en a toujours un
peu quand on est on est patron d'une
entreprise n'importe laquelle d'ailleurs
mais là la nuit je suis tout le temps de
réfléchir
je le dis tout le temps en train de
réfléchir à ce qui va nous tomber sur la
gueule voilà nous arrivons en pleine
campagne
alors nous allons arriver dans une boîte
de nuit comme la plupart des boîtes de
nuit l'extérieur c'est pas très joli
moi je le dis moi même mais l'intérieur
on aime ce club il représente quoi pour
toi ma vie ma vie depuis que depuis qq
tige est toujours assez pas rêver de
boîtes de nuit mais j'avais toujours
rêvé d'avoir mon entreprise à moi quand
je travaillais je m'étais toujours de
l'argent de côté pendant dix ans je vais
m'acheter une maison j'ai essayé de
m'acheter un commerce c'est ce que j'ai
fait en 2010 donc évidemment quand on
l'achète bas on met tout son coeur je me
souviens de d beaucoup de soirées où il
y avait la queue de l'entrée là où il ya
souvent le physio qui décide de qui rend
tout bas et et ça faisait ça à elle
et puis des fois jusqu'à là bas quoi des
fois c'était une heure et demie deux
heures d'attentes pour entrer dans la
discothèque quoi bon ben là c'est à dire
que toi tu as de la chance tu ne vas pas
tendre savent aller vite
voilà les aides du gouvernement
permettent à mathieu de conserver son
établissement et de payer les charges
mensuelles
ces aides s'élève jusqu'à 15000 euros
par mois mais comme la plupart de ses
confrères depuis la fermeture de son
club il ne sait verser aucun salaire sur
notre compte personnel nous avons touché
0 euros c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas de
rsa on a pas de chômage
on n'a pas de chômage partiel nous
sommes des travailleurs indépendants
comme la plupart des gens qui sont
insérés avant d'être patron de sa
discothèque mathieu était commercial
dans l'automobile un boulot qu'il a
décidé de reprendre dans les prochains
jours
et puis après je sais qu logiquement
effectivement le jeu vers tomber je vais
être utile je vais vendre des voitures
enfin vendre des voitures gérer un
garage là je redeviens utile là c'est
important c'est très important ça le
syndicat national des discothèques et
lieux de loisirs a proposé de
transformer les discothèques ont centres
de vaccination le temps de la crise sur
1580 discothèques en france 130 ou
fermer définitivement leurs portes
depuis mars 2020 mathieu déplore le
traitement du gouvernement à l'égard de
leur situation et le truc qui me fait
péter un plomb c'est quand je les
entends tous tous les politiques tous
que gauche-droite milieu en face quand
il parle du chr bord des liens des chrd
discothèque ils l'oublient tous il
notamment la télé encore mais j'avais
cafés hôtels restaurants discothèques
c'est pas compliqué je veux dire aller
mais qu'ils ont fait l'ena ils doivent
s'en rappeler quand même des eaux usées
qu'un bac mais j'arrive à m'en rappeler
mais elle est encore hier vers ans à tf1
cafés hôtels restaurants
j'aurais dû taper dans le dos au sort
discothèque on est concerné on est dans
le même bateau
non non on est à part et est donc deux
fait on le voit bien dans le traitement
on n'est pas traitée pareil que les
autres